في هذه الاثناء تعلن اسرائيل اليوم انها
اقترحت استضافه محادثات بين قائدي طرفي
النزاع في السودان لوقف اطلاق النار واوضح
وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي الي كوهن ان
اسرائيل تعمل منذ دلاع القتال في السودان
عبر قنوات مختلفه من اجل التوصل لوقف
لاطلاق النار مشيرا الى ان التقدم الذي
تحقق خلال الايام القليله الماضيه في
المحادثات مع الجانبين واعد جدا وكان موقع
اكسيوس قد قال في وقت سابق ان الاداره
الامريكيه اطلعت على المقترح الاسرائيلي
بشان الوساطه وان اسرائيل نصقت جهودها
معها ومع دول في المنطقه منها الامارات
الدكتور زياد ماجد استاذ العلوم السياسيه
بالجامعه الامريكيه في باريس دكتور كيف
تنظر الى ما تقول اسرائيل بانها وساطه
نسقتها مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
واصبحت متقدمه
وخاصه بدعوه الجنرلين الى اسرائيل
اسرائيل تحاول طبعا من جهه ان تبيض صورتها
وتبدو بسيطا في عمليه تفاوض من اجل وقف
اطلاق نار ومن جهه ثانيه لديها منذ فتره
العديد من المصالح في السودان ان بسبب
الموقع الاستراتيجي على البحر الاحمر وعلى
مشجر نهر النيل او بسبب كل الثروات في
السودان وتماسه مع الذهب وغير ذلك وسبق
لوزير الخارجيه ان استقبل مفردين سودانيين
والعلاقه ان مع البرهان او مع حميد قائمه
وتحاول اسرائيل ان تسوق لوشنطن تحديدا ان
دورها يمكن ان يكون مميزا عن ادوار اطراف
اقليميه اخرى مثل مصر او الامارات ما الذي
يميزه دكتور اذا سمحت في هذه النقطه يعني
بالتنسيق مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ما الذي تمتلكه اسرائيل ولا تمتلكه اطراف
فاعله في المشهد السوداني كما تفضلت وهي
السعوديه والامارات
السعوديه والامارات ومصر تدعي اسرائيل
انها على علاقه جيده بالطرفين على عكس
علاقه الدول الاقليميه التي تميل اما لطرف
او لطرف اخر او حساباتها ما زالت مرتبطه
بمن سيتقدم عسكريا ضد الاخر تدعي ان
علاقتها المتوازنه مع الطرفين تسمح لها
بدور اضافي وتخوف واشنطن من ان عدم القيام
بدور وساطه من هذا النوع قد يترك فلسطين
وروسيا ادوارا تضاف الى الادوار الاقليميه
وتخرج واشنطن اكثر من المعادله وهي التي
تراقب من دون ان يكون لها دور فاعل فتحاول
اسرائيل ان تستفيد من هذا الظرف وان
تستفيد ايضا من الاندفاع السودانيه التي
سبق وحصلت تجاهها والتي كانت مرتبطه برفع
العقوبات وبالتطبيع الدولي مع الخرطوم
وغير ذلك مما عده
العسكريون السودانيون وسيله من خلال
اسرائيل للعوده الى مجموعه يعني علاقات
ديناميات دولية دكتور مانعكاسات هذا في
حال تم بطبيعه الحال منعكاساته على الدول
العربيه في السودان وفي افريقيا ايضا
هو بالطبع خطير جدا لان السودان هو واحد
من المداخل الكثيره لاسرائيل نحو القاره
الافريقيه حيث تبني تحالفات وعلاقات
واستثمارات وتريد ان تظهر كلاعب اساسي في
مناطق افريقيه محدده لديها علاقات في
منطقه القرن الافريقي لديها علاقات في
افريقيا الوسطى في اكثر من مكان ومن خلال
السودان والسودان الجنوبي لديها ايضا حضور
فيه تريد ان تظهر كلاعب مؤثر في افريقيا
وهي القاره المقبله على تطورات ديموغرافيه
واقتصاديه كبيره في ظل تراجع اهتمام دولي
ببعض بلدانها ومجتمعاتها تريد اسرائيل ان
تكون لها في الساحه الافريقيه حضور اساسي
وهذا طبعا مضر لكل الدول العربيه ان في
شمال افريقيا او للمنظومه الاقليميه
العربيه المترنحه والداخله الى تنافسات
اضافيه من خلال حرب السودان الان ومن خلال
ملفات عديده ما زالت شائكه فاسرائيل
بالطبع تريد ان تخرج الدول العربيه من
المعادله او ان تترك بعضها مرتبكه مع هذا
الطرف او ذاك لتبدو هي فوق الارتباكات
وقادره على التعامل مع الجميع شكرا لك
الدكتور زياد ماجد استاذ العلوم السياسيه
بالجامعه الامريكيه في باريس